Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
March.
Um,
what does it March 16th match match 68th,
2015.
How's it going?
I'm kind of under the gun here.
I am,
uh,
trying to do this podcast as quickly as I can.
I have a weird travel week where,
uh,
right now it's Sunday night and um,
our Sunday afternoon and,
uh,
I'm doing my final two shows at the punchline in Atlanta ever.
Um,
so one of my favorite standup comedy clubs,
um,
that I ever got to work at.
I absolutely love this place.
I started talking about it last week,
but um,
okay.
Basically,
I don't know what happened.
They lost their lease.
I guess they're redoing the building or some shit like that.
So now they have to move it.
It's literally a standup comedy museum and uh,
they were nice enough to ask me if I wanted to do one more night and that's what
I'm doing.
And as you can hear my voice as much better.
It's a little fucked up,
but I'm doing much better.
And a old Billy freckles.
All Billy freckles is back in the gym.
Um,
I'll talk about that in a second,
but I do have to hype something.
I have a movie coming out this week.
Sorry.
Few more cops here.
Um,
a movie that a buddy of mine,
Jordan Ruben directed called Xom beavers.
That's right.
Zombie beavers.
You know,
one of the bucket list things you have to check off as an actor.
At some point you gotta be in a movie about zombies.
I mean,
that's just my own opinion.
I am just a comedian who tries to act every once in a while,
but as far as I'm concerned,
you know,
there's a few bucket lists scenes you have to do,
right?
You got to get interrogated at some point,
get punched in the face and act like you,
you would actually wouldn't tell the people shit.
Right?
You got to do that scene.
You got to do the scene where you get chased down the alley and you throw the
trash can down and the cop leaves over it and you get to the chain link fence.
He's dark,
right?
As you're halfway up,
they grab you and they pull you back down.
You've got to do that one.
Um,
you got to get shot and killed,
which I did.
I got shot and killed in a standup guys got killed by Al Pachino.
Huh?
It doesn't get any better than that.
So once you've checked those off,
there's only one thing left to do.
You got to do a fucking Zombie movie.
You have to do a Zombie movie as far as I'm concerned.
All these fucking English conch who go over there and you know what an Oxford,
wherever the fuck they go to learn how to act.
Then they come over here and they can do an accent like they're from Rhode
Island and everybody gets all blown away.
Fuck all those guys,
unless an women,
unless they did a Zombie movie.
So anyways,
a buddy of mine,
Jordan Rubin,
um,
that's making this movie,
it's about Zombie beavers.
Beavers that turned into zombies.
Oh,
he's turning the genre right on its ear.
Obviously the movie is making fun of Zombie movies and it's,
it's well aware how ridiculous Zombie beaver movies are.
Beavers that are zombies,
I should say.
So please spare me the,
uh,
dude.
How much money did you need that you took a part in this fucking,
it's a fun ass fucking movie.
Um,
I got to do one scene in it with a buddy of mine.
and uh,
you probably won't recognize him cause he's got on a wig and a mustache and a
without giving away too much.
I think work without us.
The movie doesn't work.
Okay.
And that might sound arrogant,
but if you watched the storyline,
it doesn't work.
So it comes out March 18th.
You know,
go eat a pot cookie.
Go down there,
go check out Zam Beavers,
uh,
um,
directed by a good friend of mine,
Jordan Rubin,
who I actually,
uh,
when I first came down in New York City,
I used to do open mikes and work at the Boston comedy club and all that shit way
back in the day.
Me and him,
you know,
he used to perform in front of like fucking eight people around midnight or
whatever.
So,
um,
you know,
it's great to see him move up the ranks.
He's now directing movies and shit like that.
And he said,
I got this over the top crazy fucking movie.
Uh,
you got to come down and have a fun,
it's a one day thing and,
and I'm not gonna lie to you dude,
I had a great time.
So check it out.
Have a good time,
but please don't fucking text me.
Like I thought this movie was saving private Ryan.
Okay,
I understand what it is.
Alright,
so spare me your fucking shaking my head tweets and you know,
your whole,
I have the world figured out.
Fucking horseshit.
All right.
Just have a good time with it is what it is.
You know what I mean?
Um,
you know,
I was reading,
actually written an article,
uh,
on the way out here that somebody sent to me where Patton Oswald was getting
interviewed in some magazine that I guess he's had issues with.
And um,
I almost fucking ate the magazine.
It was so fucking frustrating.
Listen to him,
trying to convey to the person writing it like it's just this,
this fucking judging of standup.
Like,
well,
don't we have to write to say our opinion about the joke?
Like you're not a fucking comedian,
comedian,
this fucking thing where it's like these selfish assholes just sit in a crowd
and listened to an hour's worth of standup where everything under the sun is
getting trashed and they're laughing along with it and having a great time and
then all of a sudden one joke they don't like and they're like,
wait a minute,
is he,
is he serious?
Now?
Does she really mean that?
It just like that whole philosophy,
like if you do like a rape joke or something like that,
like that's somehow going to make somebody who wouldn't have raped somebody then
go out and rape somebody.
You know what I mean?
I grew up watching Richard Pryor.
I never freebased.
I never shot a car and made the engine block came out.
I didn't have the cops come to my house all day.
I never lit myself on fire,
none of that.
I never went to illegal crap games,
you know,
I never even been to a whorehouse.
Okay,
Hey,
I pick up my hookers on the street.
Okay.
Um,
you know what I mean?
Just this fucking,
this stupid ass outrage about nothing.
And meanwhile,
meanwhile,
you've got a group of people in this country,
a small group of people in this country that literally turned the food supply in
the poison,
which to me is the biggest terrorist act against this country that I can think
of every day we're eating the shit that's going to give us fucking cancer.
Everybody,
you know what I mean?
And these fucking jerk offs or are breaking people's balls who are out there
now,
please don't die.
Please don't die.
Is this thing that I,
and I'm me here,
hang on,
hang on.
Is this the headphones?
Is it,
oh,
it's the headphones.
I'll fuck.
I thought my battery's dying.
That's fucking hilarious.
Right in the middle of making a great point.
So these guys are too busy,
you know,
rather than dealing with like real problems are sitting there breaking comics
balls that are on open mics fucking around fucking around.
Ah,
Jesus,
it,
it drives me up the fucking wall.
So I was reading it because I have tremendous amount of respect for pat and it
fucking,
you know,
he's one of the best in the business and listening to this fucking person going
like,
well,
what about this?
The fact that a comedian has to debate,
stand up comedian on an eyeball to eyeball level with someone who isn't a
standup comic and they literally think that the points that they're making are
just as legitimate as the comedians is one of the most fucking arrogant things.
Like,
look,
I know a little bit about cars,
but I wouldn't sit there debating what's a better design with a fucking
mechanic.
I guess mechanics don't design them.
They fix up whoever the fuck fixes and,
but right there,
that's my argument.
I don't know enough about cars to go eyeball to eyeball with somebody.
Jesus fucking Christ.
What kills me is the bullshit that they're talking about now in comedy clubs.
It has been going on for 40 fucking years in comedy clubs and nothing bad ever
happened.
But now there's social media and everybody has a fucking camera in a goddamn
opinion.
And now there's this,
this running around like the fucking sky is falling because you didn't like the
answer to knock knock who's there.
It's fucking unbelievable.
These fucking
like,
I don't know who that person is,
but the level of jerk off that they are arrogant fucking ass that they think
that they can just sit there and,
and like they have this valid point on set up and punch lines with a standup
comedian.
Jesus fucking Christ.
I will never understand it.
I will never understand people that actually go to a comedy club and get
offended.
I just,
I don't understand it.
And if you get offended,
that's tough shit.
Okay.
You went out to a comedy club.
All right.
That's too fucking bad.
Yeah,
that's on you.
All right.
I'm going to say this the last time.
If you fucking want to have a leg to stand on,
hire a comedian for your own private party and tell the person the parameters to
perform within.
All right?
Other than that,
you don't have a leg to stand on.
And these fucking conch on these stupid ass websites who watch a clip of
somebody performing in the comedy club and they get mad at the comic.
The comic is guilty of nothing other than trying out material in a comedy club.
If you want to get upset,
get upset with the person who videotaped it,
who was told not to,
and they're the ones that uploaded it and brought it into your fucking eggshell
fucking world.
All right,
Jesus fucking Christ,
but patent.
What about this?
I've never done standup.
Is this a valid fucking point?
Jesus Christ.
This is fucking the arrogance of that.
The fucking arrogance of it.
Unbelievable.
Anyways,
we'll all shit new crowd.
Don't I have a row?
Everybody's so fucking special now.
Everybody's feelings is so fucking God damn special.
Grow a Dick.
Okay,
let it will slide off your fucking back for Christ's sake and fucking move onto
the next joke.
You bunch of babies.
What a bunch of fucking,
I've never had such a fucking pussy time to be living in yet.
Some of the most psycho gangster shit is going down and nobody's fucking
focusing on it.
How they got gradually,
they're actually talking about climate,
you know,
that,
that could be the number one threat against Americans is Miami is starting to
slip into the fucking ocean and they're breaking somebody's fucking balls.
A bottle relationship joke that they told in a strip mall in a fucking funny
bump that's getting more goddamn attention.
Anyways.
All right,
I'm off my fucking soapbox.
Sorry.
So anyways,
let's plow ahead here.
Uh,
this is one of my favorite times a year as far as,
uh,
this is when I,
I watch hoop.
I don't watch pro hoop.
I watched college hoop and I don't get into the whole fucking march madness,
the big dance.
I liked the regionals,
the big 10 championship and watching right now where Wisconsin was down by 11,
their biggest deficits of the season right now,
they got a tied up 67 up.
You're probably asking yourself,
well,
who your for here bill?
I'm actually for Wisconsin.
I have some friends that went to,
to university in Michigan.
So,
uh,
I think Michigan state's more of an arch rival
and,
uh,
I dunno,
I'm kind of partial to all those fucking state.
So,
uh,
I like all those states that everybody basically shits on.
I gotta be honest with you or the sections of the country,
the flyover states,
the south,
you know,
those are some of those myths states in the Pacific northwest.
I fucking love all those places.
Um,
and I plan,
you don't want to,
I want to do,
I got this southern bus tour coming up,
which I'm so ridiculously excited.
I can't fucking wait to get on the bus with law head coach and a Versie and uh,
just go to,
you know,
a bunch of cities.
I never,
I've never been to Knoxville,
Tennessee and it's going to kill me that there's not a fucking football game
going on.
Um,
but I blew through Memphis one time really quickly.
I'd never been to Shreveport.
I never,
I've never even done standup in Mississippi.
So,
uh,
to be 23 years into the business and to be excited about coming out to all these
new places.
I can't fucking wait.
I got this killer poster that,
uh,
that I'm going to be a whore myself out,
you know,
selling it at the end of every show,
I'm going to autograph all of them.
And,
um,
I can't wait and I'm thinking about doing another bus tour later on this year
where I go through,
uh,
like,
you know,
Kansas,
Nebraska,
Wyoming is the last state I need to performance.
So I got to do a gig out that way.
Go through Montana,
the Dakotas,
um,
dad,
whole fucking part of the,
uh,
the country.
Um,
I dunno.
Good people,
good food.
I like it.
You know what I mean?
And I know whatever,
some of the dumb shit that people on the coasts give people shit about in the,
in the middle of the country.
Like,
cause they know what's going on more in the fashion world
or different kinds of music or,
or fucking whatever.
And like,
meanwhile,
like the middle of the country,
it's like our food supply,
you know,
out of these fucking headphones are driving me fucking nuts.
Come on,
man.
Um,
or like,
uh,
you know,
you know all these morons who don't know who the F I don't know,
whatever you consider,
uh,
you know,
they don't know where to get good Sushi,
but they can fucking take apart a car and put it back together better than when
it came from the factory.
I mean,
there's a lot of fucking cool shit out there,
I think.
Anyway,
so I'm beyond excited for that.
Uh,
the first week,
uh,
the end of the tour,
we,
uh,
we ended up in New Orleans and we spend an extra day in New Orleans,
which is going to be the shit.
And then the last,
uh,
the last night of the tour,
we're going to be at the Kentucky Derby.
So that's about as good as it fucking gets.
So,
um,
tickets are on sale for all dates right now.
Go to [inaudible] dot com um,
pick up a pair and a,
we'll come down and we'll give you,
we'll give you a fucking money's worth.
So anyways,
I mentioned it'll,
Billy freckles was back in the gym and um,
you know,
I don't know the holidays.
And then I did that,
that fucking trip through,
uh,
you know,
Australia,
New Zealand,
New Zealand and Southeast Asia.
A combination of that,
the Rose Bowl and all that,
uh,
it became a belly fat again.
I got up to like a buck 84,
so fucking pissed at myself,
man.
I was down to my fighting weight when 68 to [inaudible] 72.
So this time I've decided not only to get myself back in shape,
I'm going to say what,
wait,
I'm going to be,
you know,
even though I'm not going to fucking do some dumb shit and stand on the scale
and show it to you guys,
but just the mere fact that I'm going to be,
um,
was this way too fucking quiet.
I'm such a dumb cunt when it comes to this shit.
Um,
just to,
um,
mmm.
Just so I'll fucking stick with it.
I keep trying to get down to the last time I had a flat fucking stomach and I
had abs.
I was a buck 62.
The closest I've ever gotten was one 67,
but even then,
even then,
I don't know how to do it right.
I still had like the belly,
you know what I mean?
Cause you start dieting and you actually end up losing muscle and that type of
shit.
But I'm going to try to figure out how to do it without going to GNC and getting
that awful fucking cancerous shit.
Whatever the fuck that's,
there's no fucking way that stuff is good for you.
That science,
that powdered shit that the FDA doesn't even have to look at to see if it's bad
for you.
Um,
someone was telling me all of that shit though.
Those milks that are supposed to build muscle so I don't get in trouble.
Um,
yeah,
that they have like metals in them.
I Dunno,
there's other shit have metals in it.
I have no fucking idea.
I don't know.
I'm drinking a bottle of water here.
This was probably bottled like fucking 10 years ago.
Sat in a fucking warehouse.
God knows what the Hell is in my system now.
But anyways,
just for the pure vanity,
uh,
of it.
I want to see if I can get back down there.
So,
uh,
I've been hitting the fucking elliptical and a,
I was doing good man.
I got down to like a buck 78,
but I fucked up last night cause I'm,
I made homemade Ravioli first time I ever try doing that.
And I watched this video
that these people put up of their right off the boat,
Italian grandmother.
And uh,
if you guys have listened as podcast,
if you knew the podcast,
I fucking love Italians.
I love their country.
I love their food.
I like their cars.
I like the flashy shit that they're into,
you know what I mean?
Um,
versus he,
oh,
he says I'm a closet fucking Italian,
so it's not enough for me to go to Italy and eat the guide them food.
I got to figure out how to at least make an attempt at making it.
So,
um,
okay.
You know,
I actually,
you know,
I've got some Semolina right?
And I fucking did the whole welfare to eggs per pound.
I made a pound of this shit.
And,
um,
my fucking the,
the actual pasta part of it.
The uh,
yeah,
the fucking um,
the Ravioli Park came out great.
The filling I had to wing because they didn't really say what the recipe was,
so I kind of eyeballed it and I also forgot to add an egg to it.
So,
uh,
it tasted a little weird.
It was a little too sweet and some sugar and a little bit of cinnamon in it with
some ricotta cheese.
And right there you're like,
wow,
that's fucking a weird,
okay
group of flavors there.
You gotta make sure everything's right.
And I tried to eyeball it,
so,
um,
but my big fucking thing is the Ravioli thing that I have.
I have like a tray while your weight lay one sheet down and then you put the
filling in it in each one of the things and then you lay another one,
you do an egg wash and lay another one on top and then you got this roller
thing.
Don't get those,
those things fucking suck.
Just get the stamp.
Because even after all that bullshit,
this is the second time I tried to make it like 30% of them exploded and all the
filling came out anyways when I was,
uh,
when I was in the midst of a trying to cook the fucking things.
But um,
I dunno,
that's three hours of my life.
I'll never get back,
but I figure each time I do it,
I'll get a little bit better.
Um,
so whatever.
What else am I doing here?
I'm sorry guys.
This is all over the fucking map.
I literally just landed and I got to do a show here that picking me up in a
fucking an hour.
So I'm going to wrap this thing up and put on my,
my,
uh,
my stage makeup before I get on a,
I get on stage.
I don't even know if they've even sent me to fucking advertising if I got
anything.
Meanwhile,
as I'm looking this up,
how about those fucking Bruins?
Huh?
What do you think about them?
Um,
those mother fuckers were playing mediocre all goddamn year and then finally,
I don't know what's happened.
Like they had a nice little run there right before the all star break.
And then all of a sudden,
uh,
you know,
they went right back to,
when to lose to win one,
lose three,
when to lose one that bullshit.
And an al of a sudden they're playing,
playing for their playoff lives.
Uh,
beat the penguins.
Who did I see a beat recently?
I've been all over the map.
I know they'd be Detroit,
they'd be Philly.
They beat the penguins.
They be Tampa Bay there on a nice little run here.
MMM.
You know,
it'd be nice if we could,
uh,
and we got swept by the Canadians this year,
but it's just,
uh,
you know,
it's just regular season.
You get into the playoffs,
anything can fucking happen.
And,
uh,
I still think the a Stanley Cup winner is going to come out of the west,
which means once again,
the Montreal Canadians will go home couplets,
which really makes me fucking happy.
I,
you know,
what I get so excited about is that when they sweep us in the regular season,
I get,
I get text messages from Montreal Canadien fans.
Like they're legitimately excited that they swept the Bruins.
I mean,
it's a fucking compliment.
Back in the day,
they didn't give a fuck.
They didn't win a cup.
It was a failure.
Now they're celebrating shit that they did in March.
I just love,
I just love that.
Now there's that.
There's actually 30 fucking teams,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
All that fucking bullshit goes out the goddamn window.
You know,
when you competing with five other fucking teams and you and you get first
chance to sign anybody within a 200 mile radius of your goddamn city and you
live in Montreal.
Yeah.
It's a bit of an advantage.
I'd say.
I'm going to go out on a limb and say,
you're going to go on a little bit of a run there.
Fucking Bruins.
We had first dibs on the best player from Vermont
telling you they got this kid down there and in fucking a Woonsocket,
Rhode Island.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
plowing ahead here.
I might have to stop this fucking podcast.
I haven't got any of my information here and we want inflammation,
inflammation,
Hawaii.
The new number two.
Who's number one.
Oh,
by the way,
if you don't want to ruin that,
um,
that Shit I was imitating last week,
about that rich guy,
that guy,
I never knowingly lied.
I never,
I'd never purposely knowingly lied.
Um,
there's some news about him in the,
uh,
in the papers.
Just please do not look at it,
uh,
if you're watching that series because a,
it kind of ruins the series,
um,
one way or the other because it's basically you're trying to guess whether or
not this guy will ever get,
uh,
I dunno.
Brought to justice.
Um,
so there's some information there that,
that I shouldn't have said that shit.
Now people are going to look it up and just fucking tweeted anyways.
It's such cons.
Where the fuck is my God,
this is the time when I usually do the advertising.
Why?
Then you say,
oh,
I might have to do this as segments.
You know what,
I'm just gonna act like I'm going to,
I'll just say them doing advertising.
I'll edit it in later.
Okay.
We will be right back with the Monday Barney podcasts after these messages.
Alrighty.
And we are back.
Wasn't that a great read that I did in the future and the fucking future.
Okay.
I woke up this morning,
but I do buy their boob.
And a last night I had a 7:45 AM flight,
right.
So my wife's 3.0 for Wisconsin,
there are 75,
69 with two minutes ago.
So I woke up last night,
I told my wife that I had the 7:45 AM flight.
She goes,
you know what,
I'll give you the ride to the airport.
Oh,
all right,
you're a sweetheart.
And then she mentioned that there was the La Marathon.
And uh,
I was like,
well,
we'll get up early,
we'll be fine,
but blah,
blah,
blah.
So we go,
we wake up in the morning and uh,
we start driving down the street in every fucking street is blocked off.
So,
um,
I ended up jumping on the highway just cruising down to the lax and,
and she kept bitching about the traffic she was gonna run into and I was going
to look at the other side of the fucking highway.
There's nothing here.
Stop being such a pussy.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
My life is it perfectly comfortable.
You know,
women are right this second,
the fucking AC is one degree too fucking cold or it's too hot.
They just start bitching.
You know what I mean?
And for some reason we don't just go ass to shut up.
You don't.
I don't know why we don't do that.
Why we don't do it more often.
They're just fucking addicted to fucking complaining.
So she's bitch,
Moan and complain and rang,
Rah,
all this fucking crap about the goddamn traffic.
Meanwhile,
if she had a 7:45 AM flight,
I would have fucking driven and then I wouldn't have given a fuck
the,
granted.
I'm a morning person.
She said to me,
she goes,
how the fuck are you this awake?
She's one of those people that hates getting up in the morning.
She's like,
I don't fuck,
are you this awake?
And it's like,
well,
you know,
I had a paper route from the time I was in third grade.
I had a paper road.
I never knowingly lied about sleeping in.
I had a paper route from third grade until freshman year of high school.
I kept that paper route until freshman year of high school to where it was like
weird.
Like I was coming up,
like my voice had changed and shit.
I was still delivering newspapers because it was considered a little kid job
before the banker is completely fucked over.
Everybody has everybody upside down on a house and now it's like actually in
adult second job delivering newspapers and um,
I kept the job cause I liked having money.
Like my whole life I had money.
Like if you had a paper route right in the third grade,
like you had no overhead.
He didn't have any rent,
you didn't have any woman in your life,
right?
You couldn't drink,
you couldn't do drugs.
It was just whatever you took home,
you had this perfect spending on football cards and fucking candy.
That's all I was the only thing I could buy.
What else?
The foils are going to buy sandwich.
I didn't give a shit.
Yeah.
So I always had fucking money and I always remember that like kids fucking
always bumming money off their parents.
Like when I got into junior high,
I didn't,
I always had like an extra five bucks on me.
Which five bucks was like having 50 bucks on you when you were in the sixth
grade?
I mean the lunches,
I swear to God with like a dollar 10 you can get doubles for two 20.
I know I'm old.
Go Fuck Yourself.
But that's what it was.
It was like a dollar 50 maybe for lunch or something.
Like it was a dollar and change.
So I remembered that people would be asking for quarters and shit like that.
I always,
I always looked and I thought they were pathetic.
Even back then I was like,
go get a fucking job.
Always bumming money off of your parents.
But then I was jealous because they got to sleep in on Saturdays and Sundays.
And um,
the paper that I delivered,
the Boston Globe and the Boston Herald came out seven days a week,
365 days a year.
I think I told this story before I went from third grade until sixth grade.
MMM.
Before I finally,
uh,
had a day off.
Yeah.
I did it every single day for like three years.
And the only reason why a dentist,
cause we finally took a family vacation,
we were gone for a week and I remember we let the,
uh,
forget who we let do the paper routes.
I think it was the newspaper company themselves.
We let them do it.
And I came back at all these fucking complaints because it was some like fucking
27,
28 year old guy who was out getting posy the night before.
So he would just drive down the street and just fucking throw them,
you know,
with a rubber band around it,
elastic,
whatever the fuck you saying you're part of the world.
Just throw them out the fucking window right into a puddle or do a shrub and no
one could find it.
And I remember coming back and everybody bitching at me.
I mean,
you know,
you always Cherub Monzo.
I wasn't here last week.
I was,
you know,
I was on vacation.
But my first one in three years,
you can't,
could you let me in the house?
Maybe I could warm up.
Do you notice my nostrils sticking together?
Every time I fucking inhale it means it's cold out.
What is your problem?
What happened the one fucking week I was on 156 week tear.
Well,
you got it in your fucking door.
Dry every God damn day.
Seven days a fucking week.
You're going to break my balls because I took a week off right there.
Right there.
That should have been,
that should have let me know.
I should have let me know what I was in for.
When you get,
when you get fucking older,
just that constant,
there's always a fucking problem.
You know what I mean?
It just somehow you just gotta like,
I dunno.
Okay.
I don't know.
I,
you know what?
If you guys can figure out a fucking way to,
to get a woman to sustain happiness,
they can get it,
but to get him to sustain it,
just go for a nice three.
Four Day was last time your wife or your girlfriend?
Three four day run was in a good mood.
Just cruising along,
letting shit just,
well,
whatever.
Don't worry about it.
It's all good.
I Dunno the fuck that I get on this fucking tangent.
I apologize.
I never knowingly trashed women.
I never knowingly lied about my experiences with them.
Wisconsin is going to win this fucking thing.
Now they're up by 10 shit.
I'll tell you a basketball.
You know [inaudible] I saw this thing today where Yell Ming.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oming is a,
he's like,
he's in China now and he has his,
he has like a,
like a fucking,
I don't know what he's doing.
He went to some big summit in Beijing,
right.
Is Poor fucking bastard.
The guys like nine feet tall.
Like his head is above the smog level in that Goddamn town and he's going in
there fighting the good fight for his people.
Right.
And that's all I'm thinking.
Like,
wow,
what a great guy.
I mean this guy's got all the money in the fucking world playing in the NBA.
He doesn't have to do this.
And he's worried about his countrymen and the guy's walking up the steps,
right?
You can just see,
you know,
fucking people like who are that tall?
It's,
it's,
they're never,
nothing's built for their size.
You know,
they fucking,
you know,
the amount of work their heart has to do to,
to fucking their hearts the same size as ours.
That's why you don't see like a bunch of Eight,
seven foot,
you know,
70 year olds,
the only guy who can think of as Bill Russell,
everybody else like dies in their 50s because your heart is the same size as a
guy,
like my size,
like five 10 and it's got a pump all that blood to your tippy toes every fucking
time.
It's a lot of God damn work,
right?
You've got the RPMS,
you'll red line in it there.
So here's the guy walking up all these fucking stairs,
eight foot tall dude,
we're in some soda,
doesn't have to be there and you should see the picture.
There's a bunch of people taking a picture of the other guy.
It's like fucking fucking,
leave me alone.
He's going in there and making sure the next time you double park,
you don't get run over by a tank.
Right.
Can you do,
the guy is solid and get the fuck out of the way.
And it was that weird.
Is that weird for me to say that?
Is that weird for me to be filibustering on my own fucking podcast because I
still haven't got the questions or any of that shit for the week and at,
I'm not so no fucking text here by the way.
I,
uh,
you know,
I told you guys that I was going to go out and buy a nice fucking car.
I know what I'm getting.
Um,
oh,
there it is.
Hey,
sorry about the delay sending now was waiting on ads.
Okay,
cool.
Um,
I know what the fuck I'm going to get and I'm not going to tell you guys,
you don't rip it up buying an old car and,
uh,
I'm going to invite an old car that's going to cost me about four grand with a
straight body and then I'm going to get the fucking interior done.
And the uh,
get it all fucking painted and right then on top it's going to look like the mid
sixties when the car came out and underneath is going to be fucking 2015.
Just like those cars I see them making on uh,
on fast and loud.
I watched that show so much.
I fucking love that show.
And I basically,
I mean I'm trying to think of a car I ever saw them make that I didn't like.
I mean,
I love most of them,
but the worst I ever had is I still liked it.
I still appreciated what they did.
They just make such great fucking cars and they got sucked into that shit and I
was just sitting there going like,
why go out?
It'd be another Douche bag driving one of these all every fucking sedan looks
like a goddamned dinner roll.
Now they all look the exact same.
Or I can go out like Richard Rawlings does and find a fucking car.
You know,
granted,
I don't know how to do it,
so I'll pay through the nose,
but I don't give a fuck.
I'll find a car that looks cool,
that has potential,
get the fucking thing painted,
Redo the interior.
Like it just came off the factory.
Then underneath,
you know,
everything is fucking 2015,
2015 technology.
That's one of,
that's,
that's my game plan.
And uh,
uh,
I'll wait till the build starts going and this one I'll actually show you
pictures of when I get this thing done.
It's,
it's,
it's going to be a mean,
mean looking fucking card.
Fortunately I have weird tastes in cars.
I like to think it's original.
You know,
every fucking jerk off baby boomer out there.
Once a Shelby,
right?
They want a GTO,
they want the fucking whatever.
What does it that 67 corvette try power thing or the split window when everybody
wants the same fucking five cars.
And meanwhile he got all these other bad ass fucking cars that are just sitting
there.
Um,
Wisconsin wins.
Was that the big 10 champion championship?
Yeah,
they got the hats on and everything.
Let's,
that's like an AFC championship had,
I don't think it is.
No big 10 champion.
Congratulations.
Congratulations to the University of Wisconsin for winning the big 10,
the 2014,
2015 big 10 basketball championship at the Ncaa Division One level.
And congratulations to stand up comedian and excellent fellow all around.
Fella named Craig,
who's from the great state of Wisconsin who actually has,
has me now.
Him and Jeff's Desario actually are two comedians that I know that are big
Wisconsin Badger fans.
So,
uh,
they actually got me into a Wisconsin plus the last time I toured through
Wisconsin.
Uh,
Nate worked with me and uh,
he knew all the spots,
all the spots to go and eat
all that fucking dairy and shit out there.
Um,
had a great God damn time.
All right,
so let's get,
let's get to some of the,
uh,
let's get to some of the fucking advertising bullshit here.
Come on,
man.
This is what,
this is one of the problems when you try to do a podcast and he's still have the
iPhone four s,
what do you want from me?
I like old shit.
For the love of God,
for the love of fucking God.
Could you load?
Could you love just one fucking time?
Hey,
why do they block your Internet at the airport?
Why do they do that?
Did they think I want to tweet that bad that I'm going to sign up for the 20
minutes.
I'm sitting at the fucking gate.
Please tell me that's failing.
Please tell me that you as a person,
you know,
draw the line there and you categorically fucking refuse to pay for Internet at
the fucking,
at the fucking,
uh,
what do you call it?
The airport.
Right.
Okay.
All right.
What am I doing here?
Lucy's kitchen.
What the fuck is that?
Oh,
that was when I was trying to figure out how long to cook the Ravioli's for.
All right,
let's see if I can get,
okay.
Get to my goddamn emails for the week here.
Come on one time.
One time.
Let's see it work.
Let's see.
At work.
And they are not here.
All right.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
You know,
I feel like right now I feel like I'm doing like a telethon and there's nobody
watching and I desperately need like college to be calling in so I can actually
fucking fill up this,
this,
this space here.
Okay.
Anyways,
what's coming up?
March madness is coming up.
Everybody,
the madness of March.
Who Do you like?
Are you filling in your brackets?
Like can't you just sit down and watch it?
You know,
you know,
I'm really getting sick of people that don't actually play the fucking game.
Getting this level of involved like you play like be like a fantasy GM,
you know what I mean?
Like,
dude,
you should see my prac and I ain't picked all the fucking,
you know what I want to see?
I wanna see you hit a fucking layup.
I want to see you go out there and take a jump.
You know what not even want us
Ella stupid ass fucking headphones.
Keep cutting out on me.
You don't even want to see you do I want to see you just run down the fucking
hall just remotely in an athletic way.
If you can do that,
then I will take a look at your bracket.
There really should be that.
You know what I mean?
Like when there's a sports bar,
before you enter the sports bar,
they should throw you a fucking music.
You get to pick your sport,
football,
basketball,
baseball or hockey.
You get to pick your sport and you get three,
three tries to hit the ball,
fucking throw a tight spiral,
go top shelf with the puck or a fucking hit,
a free throw.
You got three fucking tries.
If you can't do it,
that's it.
You're not going in the bar.
That's it.
Then he got,
I also got to do 20 pushups.
If he can't do that,
you're not allowed in.
You know,
that's a great fucking idea.
Rather than do what you usually do when you open a place as you let every
fucking animal on the planet don't come into the fucking place.
What if you actually had a sports bar and they ran it like they know those dance
clubs where the with uh,
with uh,
the ladies get all fucking dolled up and tried to go around the line,
you know,
and they let them all in and there's a guy you standing there like a jerk off
that studio 54 shit.
Like if you have the right outfit on,
you get to go in.
What if they actually did that at a sports bar?
I think that would actually,
if you actually had great food and great booze,
but you did that on the outside,
like,
all right,
dude,
here's the deal.
You know,
if you've never been here before,
we got too many apps.
UNATHLETIC Douche bags coming into this fucking facility.
All right?
We want people that I,
not only sports fans but can actually play the fucking game.
All right,
no fucking poses in here.
So pick your poison.
What do you want?
You want to pluck?
You want a basketball,
you want to football or do you want to try to hit a fucking slider?
Right?
And they literally throw you a slider with a slider.
They,
you go,
look at me,
I'm coming up with amazing ideas that would not work.
Because what would end up happening is some fat fucking blogger would go down
there with black swing glasses and this second they found out that they couldn't
go into this place that they didn't really want to go into to begin with.
They would blog about it and then they would be on TV going,
what does this say?
What does it say about society or his halo versus people?
Are you allowed to do that?
They do that at,
at um,
at those dance clubs.
If you're not good looking enough,
if you're not a Hottie,
they don't let you in.
You know,
that never offended me.
That never offended me.
I looked at that the same fucking way I looked at some classes that I was
taking.
Just certain classes when you were going through your educational system,
right?
The educational system,
I should say,
you just knew walking in you'd like,
this isn't me.
This isn't the right fit.
I'm not going to get a good grade in this.
And you just,
you just fucking accepted it.
Now,
you know I'm not good at math.
You know,
I don't like English.
History bores me and he just fucking moved on.
What can people do that at?
Clubs?
Listen,
we're sorry.
You're not good looking enough,
buddy,
buddy.
You got too many chins.
Well,
what do you want me to do?
You know,
get on the fucking treadmill.
If you're going to be that fat,
you got to show up at least with three fucking hot women,
and even then,
you know,
we got to kind of sticky in the quarter and make you look like a bouncer.
All right?
We're trying to make money here.
This is how this works,
right?
Yeah.
I have no sympathy for people when they fucking,
when it has to do with weight and they say,
you're too heavy.
And then people get mad.
It's like,
you know what?
If you actually listen to them,
you'd lose weight and you'd actually be doing yourself a solid.
These people in a round about way are actually helping you to not have a fucking
heart attack.
Have you ever looked at it that way?
Yes.
Sell fish fat cunt.
Um,
all right,
here we go.
Let's,
let's,
uh,
let's read some questions here for the week.
Um,
Oh,
you know what?
Wait a minute.
I got to read.
Uh,
let me,
let me get the advertising out of the way.
I'm not going to drop it in where I said I was going to drop it and fuck that.
Let me just blow through this.
All right.
Okay.
Bombas socks.
I have no idea what this is.
Chances are if you have feet,
you'll wear socks,
right?
Unless you're some rich kid walking around with your fucking penny loafers.
You know,
you accidentally choked your girlfriend to death during rough sex for the most
part,
right?
Unless you're homeless.
All right?
In face it,
socks haven't changed since they were invented.
They fall down,
they wear out,
and there's always that toe scene that never fits in the right place.
Our new sponsor,
Bonobos has changed all of that home saying that right bomb has decided to eat
dedicated two years to engineer socks that stay up Jesus Christ.
How much startup money did you have six months in?
Oh,
it's still looking.
The socks.
Um,
they stay up,
they last forever and they feel amazing on your feet.
Um,
for some reason they're trying to say that I have a pair on right now.
I don't,
let me guess.
I have him on and on my Dick's getting hard.
Alright.
Personalize your experience with bombers.
Example,
there's so comfortable.
The honeycomb stitching hugs your foot.
So whether you're walking or running,
your feet feel perfect.
I'm gonna tell you something right now.
This is such an embarrassing thing.
The older you get,
the more you get into socks.
If you're young,
if you're smart,
you'd get a comfortable pair of socks because you feet start to go.
Your big toe starts looking over at your other toes.
Like,
Hey,
what's going on guys?
They never noticed Joe over there for the first 30 years of our lives.
It's called hammer toes,
right?
Stop.
Hammertoes pain.
Sorry.
Um,
anyways,
the Prima cottony used is so soft.
It's amazing.
This is what I'm supposed to be saying because I'm supposed to be wearing them.
I'm wearing them right now.
And my feet are singing.
Uh,
another example,
I find myself washing them over and over so I can wear them again.
I need to get more.
Well,
I hate when they do this shit.
Don't put words in my fucking mouth.
Just send me some socks.
I'll put them on.
If they feel good,
I'll tell people they sound nice.
You guys are talking a good game anyway,
so no,
what I'm allegedly talking about,
you really need to get,
uh,
get yourself a pair.
Uh,
listen,
bombers doesn't stop with the,
uh,
with your comfort,
with every pair of socks.
Bomb is cells.
A pair is donated to someone in need because socks is,
it turns out are the number one requested item at homeless shelters.
There you go.
So you can help out your feet in somebody.
A homeless feet right now and for a limited time bombers are,
is offering my listeners 20% off their first order and free shipping.
Just go to Bombus,
B o m B a s.com/ [inaudible] all lowercase.
Do it now for 20% savings,
most comfortable socks on the planet.
And you'll be hooking up a,
uh,
a homeless dude.
All right.
Who won?
You know,
and it's also gross looking at their feet too when you walk.
when you walk down the street,
it's just peeking out from under the cardboard.
They're callous souls,
you know,
making you feel guilty about the lobster roll you're eating at the time.
Let's cover those things up.
What he say?
People get yourself some bombs.
All right?
Oh,
me undies,
everybody.
Me undies beyond these.
No most sweaty balls.
Boop,
boop,
boop.
Me undies.
Me,
you yoga.
Where Maine in the fall.
It doesn't fucking matter what season it is.
Even if you jerk off and you fucking Tj's,
you'll still be comfortable with some of your undies.
Even make up for the ladies.
Oh yeah,
keep those fucking clamps.
Nice and dry.
They really mean it now.
Bt Batou Patou more sweaty,
petite the deed to BD balls or clams and balls or clams and headache.
Suck it all right.
90%.
That's,
that's the,
you know the deal as a percentage of your life that you're in your underwear and
underwear.
It gets old fast.
You know that feeling of putting on an old saggy underwear,
you know that right?
If you underwear quit,
you balls quit and then you quit.
The next thing you know you're staring across the table at some fucking troll
you didn't even want to have a second date with right?
And next thing you know,
you've got a bunch of kids that have looked like her and half look like you.
Some half saggy ball look and kids,
isn't it time you got a good pair of underwear you need to know about me?
undies.com [inaudible] is the most comfortable underwear you will ever wear.
And it's insane how good they make you feel.
They fit perfectly.
They don't ride up on your balls and they literally pull moisture,
grouse away from your skin.
See a state scores stay cool.
Uh,
they have cool styles for both men and ladies and they all look great.
How do you get them?
Well,
all you gotta do is a,
where the fuck is it?
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr and get 20% off your first order and free
shipping.
Save even more.
When you buy a pack of them,
they guarantee that you're going to be happy with them or your first pair will
be absolutely free.
All right,
two more.
Real quick here.
Dollar Shave club,
everybody,
you heard me talking about?
Dollar Shave club.com the company that delivers amazing razors for a few bucks.
I know our razor that costs a few bucks.
Delivering a great shave seems too good to be true,
right?
But you really have to try the raises.
The dollar shave club.com raises gives you the most amazing shave you'll have in
years.
Don't pay triple the pipe price at some cvs or Duane aid,
Duane Reed,
whatever the fuck they call it.
Rite aid.
Don't pay triple the price.
Don't stand there with a frigging.
Have to unlock the thing.
They'll deliver them right to your door without charging you an arm and a leg.
It's a,
I'm a massive celebrity.
This is their content and I'm constantly getting my picture taken by the pop
Paparazzi or I'm on a TV show in high definition.
I can not be seen with Nixon cuts all over my face.
I have to shave with a high quality razor.
A don't be fooled by the price.
These raises are legit and you will never go back.
Plus they got Dr Carver's easy Shave Balm.
It's phenomenal.
If you're still using old fashioned shave shaving foam,
you're a loser and I feel bad for you.
Try Dollar Shave club.com/burr a today to get started.
You wish you had started sooner.
That's dollar shave club.com/bar all right,
last but not least,
legal zoom.
Everybody.
If you are thinking about starting a business and not lying now is the best time
to do it.
It's national.
Start Your business month@legalzoom.com it's never been easier to start building
your future.
Legal Zoom provides the support you need for more than 10 years.
They've helped a million businesses,
owners,
million business owners just like you.
Hey,
if you need advice for your business,
no fucking problem.
Legal Zooms,
not a law firm,
but you know what?
They'll hook you up with a trusted attorney to provide you some guidance for
your specific situation.
It is the best part during national starch,
your business month,
which is every month of the frigging year.
Evidently,
legal zoom is offering an attorney consultation for only 50 bucks,
50 bucks.
The guy tells you what you need to do to start your business.
All right.
If you're unsure about the best way to start or if you already run a business
and need some advice,
this offer is for you.
Get legal advice for your business with no further obligation for a low one time
costs.
Go to legalzoom.com today to try to find out more attorney,
uh,
consultations are provided by independent attorneys available in most states.
Get the legal help you need for your business@legalzoom.com and enter bur bur in
the referral box,
uh,
to save even more legalzoom.com Promo Promo Code Burr.
A legal help is here.
Jesus just stumbled through those this week,
Huh?
All right,
let's get to the content
here before we wrap this fucker up.
Um,
all right.
By the way,
if you also,
if you want to send an email to the podcast,
uh,
the email is bill at the Mlm,
podcast.com and if you'd like to follow me on Twitter,
then Monday morning podcast,
it's at the m m podcast.
That's the,
our Twitter handle and a,
if you'd like to support this podcast anytime you go to amazon.com just go to
[inaudible] dot com first go to the merchant page,
click on the Amazon link,
it'll take you right there.
I just get credit for driving traffic there.
It doesn't cost you any more money.
Um,
I would really appreciate it.
We here who never lie.
All right,
heat spelled.
Um,
hey Billy.
Sweet stack.
I don't know what that means.
Um,
no,
he sweat stack.
Okay.
Sweat stack stack of once.
What snack?
A sweaty money.
I Dunno what the fuck that means.
I'm like balls on top of each other.
My lane sideways on a couch.
It's only sweat stack I can think of.
Um,
saw on la time articles about how California has a year of water left if there
wasn't a crazy breakdown of society.
Rather,
just a gradual exodus of California.
Where would you go and how long would you wait it out?
Um,
where would I go?
I go to Alabama.
Okay.
Man,
houses are cheap.
You got to deal with hurricanes.
But a,
I go to Alabama and I would either pick the crimson tide or I pick Auburn
and I would just get involved in that.
And then I would just be a comedian from there.
Or,
you know,
if the oceans are truly rising,
I guess I would move to,
uh,
I dunno,
maybe Tennessee.
I like to south,
I'd,
I'd move to like western Tennessee somewhere between Nashville and Memphis.
I would live there and get myself a spread drive,
my old truck.
And,
uh,
I dunno,
fly out to my gigs.
I'd probably do that.
Um,
I don't think California only has a year of water left.
I think it's going to rain between now and then,
but we'll see.
Who knows?
I don't know.
What are you gonna do?
I mean,
I'm in this business.
I have to be in California.
I have to live on a fault line.
And,
uh,
I don't give a shit where you live.
We are going to be affected by global warming and the end is going to come.
Uh,
there's too many fucking people were too God damn selfish and it is our destiny
to destroy ourselves.
Now,
having said that,
go out there and have a good time while it lasts.
That's how I look at it.
Isn't that uplifting?
Well,
great.
All right.
Weight loss.
Um,
Billy,
Billy boy.
All right.
I've been dying to email you for months,
but I figured I'd wait.
Okay.
That doesn't make any sense.
I lost weight.
My man and I got up girlfriend out of it.
Oh.
And I got a girlfriend out of it.
I got a promotion due to the extra confidence that the very first podcast
episode when you started fat shaming,
I was all in.
I started waking up early and running.
There you go,
man.
There you go.
Then about a weekend to running.
I was listening to the podcast during a run and you mentioned Cleo.
I started thinking,
if I'm going to be up early,
I might as well get that dog.
I always want it.
There you go.
And that's a chick magnet right there.
I started looking for a black lab,
but ended up with the pit.
I named a Mobi.
He's white with Brown spots.
Uh,
Jesus,
a fucking love those dogs.
Very rare.
I've been told anyways.
It looks like me.
If I worked out and I was a pit bull,
right?
He's got freckles there.
Anyways,
I'm down.
I'm down 82 and a half pounds as of this morning,
since October.
Uh,
the first 20 fell off.
Then it was just 10 a month.
Uh,
come back to Chicago.
Loved hearing you on the Barstool rundown.
Thanks for the honesty.
There you go buddy.
There you go.
Well,
you know what,
I let myself go a little bit here.
So,
uh,
I'm trying to do the same fucking thing.
It's kind of hard when you travel,
so I just make sure I eat right.
Like,
um,
I just walked over to this whole strip mall area and they got all,
you know,
they get an Arby's.
I never eat at Arby's.
Some about fast food,
roast beef,
always.
That's too adventurous for me,
which is hilarious because they'll eat at Mcdonald's and God knows what the fuck
that is.
You know,
I don't know what it was my whole life,
but I remember like 40 years in the meat eating Mcdonald's,
all of a sudden they had this advertising campaign now 100% real beef.
And it's like,
well,
what the fuck was it before?
Right.
It's a little unsettling.
Um,
that's awesome man.
And uh,
I'd fat shame people too.
And I in a silly way to try to get you to fucking lose weight,
but you really have to do,
you have to fat shame yourself.
If at some point you're not disgusted with yourself like this hope and being
disgusted with yourself because you know you're better than that.
All right?
What are you doing right now?
You're sitting down,
look down at your stomach.
Come on,
man.
You're better than that,
right?
You know,
you are.
You better than just give the summertime's
coming up.
Get a jump on it.
March.
Yeah.
While you're waiting like a fat lamb,
go out like a lion.
I saw this chick the other day on Allen doing these pull ups,
right?
And she said,
don't worry about uh,
losing weight.
Just worry about kittens strong first.
And that's kind of like,
I was like,
you know what?
I liked that philosophy.
Go to the gym,
get stronger.
Then all the other shit will hopefully fall into place.
That's great man.
Good for you.
Oh,
82 and a half and you fucking pounds and you need,
that's six months.
That's right through the holidays too.
Dude.
That's fucking hardcore.
And when you only started dropping 10 instead of 20,
you didn't quit like a pussy.
You kept going.
So good for you,
man.
I'm psyched you social life picked up to see that he did it.
So can you drop some weight,
get a dog and start walking around smiling at people and you know your life will
change.
All right talks bill,
my girlfriend,
soon to be wife.
I hate the word fiance.
Yeah,
I hate that word too.
It's way too fancy for what's going on.
It's my fiance.
Oh really?
Welcome to Applebee's.
And I were my,
my,
my soon to be wife and I were talking and she said I would,
I should own a Tuxedo because I'll always need one and it's better to have my
own that fits instead of getting ripped off with rentals every time.
What are you a fucking senator?
Do you own your own business where you're constantly entertaining people?
Uh,
he said,
I told her it was unnecessary.
We both have great jobs but not enough to buy a tux without thinking of reasons
why I shouldn't.
Also styles change.
I told her it'd be outdated.
Do you own,
do you own a Tux?
Nia?
Sounds like she knows a thing or two about styles.
She definitely does.
Has she ever suggested this to you?
Thanks.
And come back to Chicago?
Um,
no.
No she hasn't.
I mean,
what am I fucking James Bond?
Who needs,
who needs to own a Tuxedo?
Like
the little that you don't,
people will own Tuxedos,
like are doing something really dishonest and they're constantly have throwing
these big fucking parties because they know they're going to jail soon.
So they're trying to bang as much hot ass as they can.
They're trying to get to know as many politicians and cops as they can and
judges to try to keep their ass out of the slammer.
Other than that,
no dude,
buying a Tuxedo is about as dumb as buying a boat.
You don't buy a boat.
You want a friend who has a boat.
Okay.
You don't need a Tuxedo.
You fucking rent one,
you rent one and then you fucking give it back.
It's over.
Nobody gives a fuck.
You know what I mean?
I think anyways.
I'm trying to think why you would own a fucking Tuxedo.
And he and I never even thought,
I never even thought for one second that,
that,
that the style would change.
I'm trying to think the amount of times I've even worn a Tuxedo.
I wore one at my senior prom.
Yeah.
I think I wore one at a wedding where it was a black tie event.
MMM.
Maybe a set on the day of set a roast back at the friars club and I had to wear
one,
I think maybe three times,
three times in my life.
I'm going to be 47 in June,
Have I ever worn a Tuxedo?
MMM.
Look,
if you will fucking renting one every month and it cost you 100 bucks,
then I get,
yeah,
I guess it's a no brainer.
You'd want to go out and buy one.
What else is great?
You know,
as you get older,
your weight fluctuates.
You go up,
you go down,
you go up,
you go down.
It's a fucking pain in the ass.
You're gonna buy one in your 20s.
I mean,
it's kind of a great way to stay in shape.
That could be your fucking,
your barometer.
Can I still fit into my Tuxedo?
Shit.
God dammit.
Harnish.
Stop making banana bread.
Um,
all right.
Sharks versus helicopters,
dear Billy,
red tits.
All right.
That's just mean.
Um,
their alabaster.
I,
I guess certain fears are for certain people.
I surf and block out the fear of sharks while you fly over sharks and surfers in
a helicopter blocking out the fear of flying the helicopter.
That's why I'm in the water.
And you were flying the helicopter.
To me,
the helicopter would be scary as shit.
Love you.
MMM.
It's scarier than fucking being eaten alive by a fucking monster fish.
Okay.
Let me ask you this.
If you had to choose
between flying in a helicopter,
it loses power.
And within fucking 10 seconds you're like,
yeah.
Ah.
Slapped or being in the water,
having a shark come up to you,
take a chunk out of your leg to see what you are and see if your edible and as
you're bleeding out,
the fucking thing comes back and finishes you off.
Yeah.
I don't know,
man.
I'd rather get it all done at once.
You know what I mean?
You,
you'd,
you'd rather have the window shopping.
Slow death.
I'd like to have it done.
Nice.
And a nice and quick not to mention.
Um,
yeah.
You know,
they train you in a helicopter.
What to do if there's a problem and you have an unbelievable amount of fucking
control provided you react properly.
Like when the low Rpm Horn goes on,
you slam the collective down and you immediately start to auto rotate.
You have an unbelievable amount of control.
MMM.
In a helicopter.
Whereas with surfing,
I mean,
I don't know.
What are you supposed to do?
What?
He's supposed to punch the shark and the nose and shit.
I Dunno,
I'll take,
but dude,
I totally respect what you're doing.
Surfing looks fun as shit and it has to be fun as shit.
The fact that you would do it in what?
In shark infested waters,
which as far as I'm concerned is every is the entire ocean because that's where
all the sharks are there in the ocean.
Uh,
but they're not in this part really.
Oh,
that's interesting.
A citizen for a bill.
Have you seen the documentary on Edward Snowden?
No,
I haven't,
but I feel really bad that I haven't kept up on that cause I feel like he did me
a solid where he was making this,
this,
designing this,
whatever the fuck.
And the computer word is for it to spy on me and everybody else.
And he actually had the spine to say,
I'm not going to help you guys do this.
I want to thank he did was really patriotic and nobody had his back anyways.
He said it's really amazing.
I tried to avoid it because I don't want my blood pressure to spike getting mad
about the NSA,
a NSA's practice practices.
But it was great.
You can see how calm and thoughtful Snowden is.
He handled everything as well as he could.
Um,
citizen four is what it's called.
Well,
I will definitely watch that.
Um,
as soon as I can.
you guys should all go see that.
Watch it,
download it,
watch that.
So that's your homework for the week.
Watch citizen for trying to check out Zam beavers if you can.
And uh,
I actually watched an unbelievable movie last night.
Um,
that starts Sam Rockwell,
who really is one of the best actors of all fucking time.
He's fucking unreal.
Uh,
it's called mood.
Check it out,
man.
Really fucking freaked me out that movie.
Um,
all right,
well that's it.
People write it in an hour.
I apologize.
It's not a little bit longer,
but I'm,
I'll be doing another Thursday,
Monday morning podcast,
wherever the fuck you want to call it again this week.
So,
uh,
give you some added comedy.
It's a classic clips from the old podcasts,
and I'm,
once again,
thanks everybody for listening.
Checkouts on Beavers,
checkout citizen for checkout,
Sam Rockwell in moon,
and um,
and congratulations to Wisconsin,
but in the big 10 championship,
that's it.
Go Fuck Yourself.
So talk to you next week.